the coronation is about that he's gonna
be crowned and he'll be the head of the
state this is going to be a big
celebration and the King will get the
crown on his head
hello I would like the king to to make
to just not have teacher strikes so then
the children will have more education to
make everybody have peace and no
fighting I would like
I'd like the king to to be to help
animals and make sure that every pet has
a hand
we're very fortunate here in isleworth
town to have the whole history of the
school from when it opened in 1910 and
from our log book we can see on the 3rd
of June 1953 the children's coronation
celebrations were held owing to the
weather it was impossible to hold the
sports but games were played indoors
followed by tea with ice cream and
coronation cake each child received a
Mars bar
[Music]